hi guys Greg here and it's John here
we're gonna check out this latest cars 3
trailer excellent whoo why did I hear in
the first guy here it's a good trailer
but before we do that it's time for a
patron of the day shout out today's
patron of the day
Jeff bearskin Peterson just bearskin
Peterson you actually have to comment on
our patreon today I'm glad to help Greg
and Jon out they have been putting a
smile on my face for years I can have
this shitty of those of days at work
with customers that try to take
advantage that I can watch the real
rejects and it will put a smile on my
face
Oh buddy Jeff bearskin Peterson and
Peterson here I gotta let you know right
now no matter how much we make you laugh
your shitty days at work will still be
shitty never forget those words
inspirational motivational book I am
working on a little with reality down by
Greg Alba I will make you her your
middle name here is bare skin so I just
like to imagine you like in a Coonskin
cap or something like I'm old right I
don't imagine that's what the ladies
call him ooh
because he's got like a luscious chest
of hair yeah exactly I'll say right here
Jeff bearskins me I'm just trying to
help get the patreon a little more
notice I think you're never changing
Marga how dare you try to survive
good ready for what's coming
[Music]
derrickson storm is part of the next
generation of high street races new
report you have no idea what a pleasure
it is for me to finally beat you did you
say meet or beat I think you heard me
enjoy your retirement famous movie Osama
right there
you'll never be the race are you one's
good you can't turn back the clock kid
you can wind it up again everything
world if changing treadmills ringtones
virtual reality still working on that
and interactively simulation you have
come we got some work to do I am so
excited that I get to training that is a
worthy
the beach ate me every week federated
retired to make room that he's young
you're coming to research you'll never
be in fast to storm but you can be
smarter
good luck out there you're gonna need it
tonight when I'm done
[Music]
winning this long trailer for you
[Music]
[Applause]
alright alright so this is my lead ASG
that's on a PG it looks pretty intense
for a G their cars man I am pretty sure
what would you find no matter how
violent he gets come on around me come
early Gatto and [ __ ] up they were
blowing stuff up and they were they were
dropping anchors on his head and Lange
gonna be fine what
it'll be t word here materializing
hysteria I mean good know exactly what
it's about the Colt Ritter I know what
it's about Johnny Storm man people are
going to be buying that action figure
maybe maybe there's not really anything
to do in a Cars movie to make the
villain special unless he's got a
different cool kind of personality or
he's funny or something because right
now all I know about Johnny Storm be
he's very fast and he's the one to be
feared is a light lightning McQueen
he's like and Drago his training the lab
and his you know
yeah but Ivan Drago could have just been
a stronger boxer or Russian steroid
machine and that's what made him stand
out ok that's why we remember Ivan Drago
Johnny Storm just has a catchy name
right now and is voiced by army hammer
yeah but I don't really know Johnny
storms personality I'm hoping the movie
lives up to all this build-up of who the
hell Jackson starvin Saint John service
yeah Jackson's dorm is this all time
what makes him more than just great but
makes it more than just bad did he
sabotage McQueen I'm not sure you know
that I didn't really love cars 1 to
begin with I liked cars and knowledge
most of home exactly about it I didn't
sit through cars to I think I will
before doing this because mater is the
funniest character and there's no mater
in this tree I noticed that has ever
been made her in any of these trailers I
think mater's in it yeah
I'm pretty sure I saw em credited in the
IMDB but mater is what made cars so
special that's why cars too made the
brilliant step then making it more mater
based which kind of surprises me that
they would go back to the first one more
a lightning McQueen's kind of at the
bottom of the barrel again and he has to
find his roots in him and train all over
again why would they do that when
clearly everyone was really happy with
the direction cars to went this this
just doesn't make sense to me people
well with cars to even Abela it was you
there was layers of spying in the
international espionage day again works
fast and furious was about street racers
now they work for the government that's
where I thought cars was going and I was
happy with that direction they should
have just stuck with it I'm just kidding
I know no one likes cars - there's going
to be someone in the comments gonna be
like you know people are just one little
breath to the new cars - is actually
really hilarious - branches regulars
reaction someone inside will never
escape if a movie is universally hated
the UVU you in if you agree with that on
a YouTube video there's someone in the
comments to go this everyone's do
consider to do go to go through funding
internet whack-a-mole yeah you can get
the credit I'm seeing all these cars
three trailers they have me interested
but they don't nerves amia have made me
like really want to go revisit this you
know like you know maybe want to revisit
it the first teaser trailer yeah yeah
yeah Lightning McQueen was flipping
through the air in slow motion and it
was super serious and dark and then I
was thinking what what are they doing I
want to find out cuz crazy-ass dark
promotional material or unbelievable
amounts of trailers are releasing for
this damn movie the more I see the more
I like this was kinda like a generic car
terrific to me I think they actually
this is the edge like when we saw that
first teaser I was hooked I was like wow
okay like you you see like you
acknowledge this this is divisive enough
for the audience that you can change it
in will pay attention yeah I might be
smart in each time I've seen footage and
granted I haven't seen all the trailers
but I've seen a couple the more I know
about it yet a less interesting occasion
it looks like the kind of movie that and
still probably enjoy while there it'll
still probably thrilled it while I'm
there you know like that scene where
he's like driving around like avoiding
falling objects and there's that thing
blowing up and they're actually really
immersing into the race world like that
would probably be fun to watch and I
like the cast and everything more I see
from it the more just looks like I is
this is going to be an animated movie I
don't know if the media kind of looks
like a really high-quality
straight-to-dvd film yeah kids I'm going
to be on it like it looks it looks as if
the the animation is awesome that's
probably going to be some group like
really cool car racing sequences to
watch in the theaters however you know
fix our and Pixar I feel has this
amazing job providing amazing animation
with colorful characters and then having
like some random meaningful deep stuff
insert into the film that tends to
really hit home and here this kind of
just looks like festival entertaining
comedy moment yeah and I expected I
don't I'm not live demand a lot from
this cars are we get it welcome our
movies are interesting because cars the
vols
Pixar's different stories you know cars
is one of the one I don't know how to
describe it just seems like a more kind
of what comes off the top of your head
when you think oh animated movie like oh
here's an anthropomorphic object and
here's an adventure with you know enough
heart but cars has never been one to me
that says like oh wow like you did
something yeah
game-changing or really special with it
cars to me is kind of like a well-told
version of a certain kind of story when
you pointed out that that i do think is
kind of a drag about this is that yeah
the first movie is about lightning and
clean getting his mojo back
and while i like that this is taking
advantage of the fact he's older now and
times are a-changin Rocky Balboa I think
that's cool wallpaper I like what you
can explore with that but if we're going
to watch him get his mojo back again it
better be pretty special to make us want
to go back and revisit that Toy Story
since that's how we got
this anyway I don't want to be like a
remake of cars in disguise basically
yeah yeah exactly so softly person yeah
exactly one good breeze like what they
have different going for it is they have
a very defiant villainous and talked
about in TV spots and trailers of Josh
he's enjoying some Jack Jon Bernthal
have a checks in the storm I keep
thinking like I don't see what makes
Jackson storm such a special kind of
character in this cars franchise like
you're redoing the cars one plot sort of
what I feel can make this really like
hook me more is if you if you give me a
little more work off of Jackson storm
yeah well I want to know about his
personality because right now all I know
is that he's a be super bad yeah but if
these movies have taught me anything you
can be a better car but a heart does a
lot for your strong game right so yeah
that's otally so I don't yeah it's like
what's what's careless about this like
how am I supposed to feel about this guy
other than like yeah I don't really like
him it seems like you've got a lot of
advantages that my here hood nap
whatever we're just nitpicky I like our
me hamburger just nitpicky that's what
we're doing why go on might make a
YouTube video where you decide to
criticize things and analyze things you
should just have the general basic
opinion of everything well the first
time sure if you watch like three or
four trailers of the same yeah why you
have to be like okay like here's a
minute cuz otherwise what are you gonna
do that was our cars three rivalry
trailer rivalry Russian shatter the end
Jeff Baer scale in Liberty I hope you're
doing well my friend and hey guys we
finally want some merch we got cheese
shop Spreadshirt calm / the real rejects
go check out the t-shirts design some
iPhone cases on they're all representing
the real rejects real retail rejects
subscribe to the real rejects and go
follow ex Mary black X on Instagram she
has done all of our artworks yes she had
rific she's done these drawings back
here that people really admire so much
she's also my sister so please all
freaking follow her
you could go check out our patreon check
out all the exclusive perks over there
yeah man loving the community over there
it's a real person alive we got going on
perky it's a party and and one of the
reward tiers there's you can get a
autographed t-shirt or a picture of
Gregg's nipples and I don't like they
more people if I he'll join a patreon if
that was one of the rewards that John
Humphrey is a new instagram and twitter
handle dead follow him there way easier
that Genesis that did not fit its debt